(dramatic crescendo)
- Oh, I think she's gonna kill it.
She's going to absolutely crush it.
She knows my hand like
the back of her hand.
(electronic music)
- Feels a little warm to be Ned's hand.
It also, the callouses are not Ned's hand.
That's not Ned.
If this isn't Ned, it's so weird.
(laughter)
Okay.
We feel a pinky.
- [Voiceover] What are you thinking?
- I think that this is Ned's hand.
He has this little broken pinky area,
but also his hand is clammy,
which is sometimes a Ned thing.
- [Voiceover] Go ahead and (mumbles)
- Oh somebody's got a
really cold hand. (laughs)
And thin fingers.
Not enough flesh here.
This is not Ned's hand.
I think that hand number two is Ned.
(bouncy music)
Yes! I did it.
- She nailed it.
- I nailed it.
- Yeah she did great.
- I think I just knew
when my Ned held my hand,
and I was like "Haha!"
- That's my wife.
(jazz music)